all right Nell and Sally are in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions hey guys how
are you better than we deserve welcome
where do you guys live Dryden Michigan
okay cool Ann what's that near Flint
Detroit ah got you okay cool well
welcome to Nashville and here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off two hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars Wow awesome how long did that
take nine years two months all right
love it
making what kind of money during those
years we won 47 and up a little bit from
there
147 okay very cool now is that your
house and everything yes everything we
also put two children through college
during that time there you go free
that's exactly how you do it that's
working the baby steps perfectly yeah
very cool and been saving for retirement
I assume yes very good
good sounds like you were doing this
exactly our way and our average is about
seven years you did it in nine years
that's perfect that's exactly on
schedule
very very cool how old are you - I'm 57
55 very cool good and don't have a house
payment no house payment you're wearing
at all we almost took out another
mortgage a couple years ago to put a new
roof on a pole barn and are now 24 year
old said to us What did he say
I don't think Dave would approve of that
of course he says no Dave Dave's there's
a con artists he doesn't he's trying to
get you guys yeah he follows everything
you do now I love it well he's watched
you guys win that's why that's very fun
ngratulations so you tell me about this
journey what started you on the journey
ten years ago or so my boss at the time
peg told me about your book on tape at
Christmastime unspecial and I was gonna
get it to fix my husband because he was
the one that was the problem
mm-hmm and I listened to it first and
realized that I was a problem too and
gave it to him to listen to yeah and I
and I put on the tape
and listen to it I have grapevines and I
was working on my grapevines and darn I
was sick and tired of being sick and
tired
iiiii got that I got that statement and
I looked and I said I'm just paying the
interest on the I'm not even paying on
the principle of the credit card yeah so
we got on that we got on your page it
was very easy I will tell you it was
easy we were met very well you were when
the when the student is ready the
teacher will appear so the total money
makeover book on tape is yes and then we
did financial piece at our church and
you know even help facilitate one of
them and it was nice coming into
financial piece having already started
it several months before and being an
example for the people in the program
yeah it's very inspiring to share with
our church when we paid up everything
but our home not bad and then when you
paid off the house they got to be
dancing with yes I love it right this is
awesome so when did you pay the house
off it was it was I was going to pay it
February 15th I just couldn't take it I
paid it off February 8th we had the wire
they wouldn't accept it without it being
wired and I didn't want it to be late
and I wanted it to be the right amount
so I said I'm just sending it early I'm
done with these guys and then the week
later we got a payment book for the next
year that was probably computer
generated for our house payments for the
next year yeah with you people
so how's it for you unbelievable it's
it's it's hard to even describe you know
we've we've never been here we're now
hmm and to be here now with no debt it's
like you know the whole worlds in front
of us and even though I'm 57 you know
there I'm on step 7 where our kids our
kids are debt-free and that's why I want
to do anything I want it's all open to
me now effect if I approve
starting again yeah you can do anything
you want to do that's right exactly
right you got a lot of a lot of
flexibility so what's this house worth
well it's worth quite a lot probably a
half a million bucks with the property
excellent well that's you own it all
yeah we own every piece
we can cool you sitting on a half a
million dollar house making 147 a year
life is good right yeah you're you're in
the serious serious mode right here this
is you have lived like no one else now
you're in a position to live and live
like no one else you're right so what
advice do you have to the the version of
you 10 years ago that's out in those
grapevines right before they handed you
this tape what would you tell that guy
you see we guys like us we know it all
right no one can tell us anything and we
kind of have to take the hard road I
think and what I would tell him is is
that you have to be open when when I
came in to talk to Sally after I
listened to that tape and I said Sally
and she didn't let me finish she said oh
now wait a minute wait a minute just let
us think and you'll get it eventually
but I got it right away
and what what I the advice I'd give is
that you've got to be you've got to look
to see and do what's right and the only
thing that and by the way when you go
through that you can't do it alone you
know I was always trying to push her
because she was the problem but it
wasn't her it was this has been so good
for our marriage too it's brought us
even closer together we always had a
really good marriage but this made our
marriage great and I will tell you we've
not bought of over finances since we
started financial peace we've always
been on the same page so people say what
was the hardest part the hardest part
was getting started just sticking with
it and not making you don't make
financial decisions without each other
when you make that commitment to each
other it really deepens your
relationship you guys are incredible
you're the real deal man this is fun and
I'm honored that you're teaching a
Financial Peace University class because
they need to hear your wisdom very good
excellent job all right now in Sally
Flint Michigan area two hundred and
thirty four thousand dollars paid off
they paid off their house nine years and
two months making 147 a year count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show if you
didn't know I actually have my own
YouTube channel so I do videos twice a
week on life and money so you can click
the subscribe button to subscribe to my
channel and if you want to check out our
video right now check out the video on
how to make a budget